- What's happened
to LA, it kind of,
I always thought of LA and
even California, for sure
as kind of that hot
blonde from high school,
that was always the
belle of the ball.
Didn't have to study very hard,
phone rang every Friday
night for a date,
really was able to kind
of get by in her looks
and kind of cruise.
And now that blonde
is 47 years old
and not the bell of
the ball anymore.
And if you listen to
Gavin Newsom, that guy,
I've heard interviews
with him going,
hey man, where are you gonna go?
It's like the 47 year
old blonde saying
to the football star, hey,
don't you want some of this?
And it's like, no, nah, I can
find some of that in Texas
or Arizona or Nevada.
(soft music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
this is The Rubin report.
Joining me today is a
best-selling author,
costar of the wonderful
documentary, "No Safe Spaces"
and host of the Adam
Carolla Show podcast,
Adam Carolla, welcome
back to the Rubin report.
- Always good to be back, Dave.
- All right, Carolla,
we got a lot to do here
because this is my
last interview of 2020.
And we said, who can we get
on the show to end the year
that is not completely
fucking bananas.
And you were on the shortlist.
There were only about
two other people
and we couldn't get
them, so we got you.
You're on the shortlist
of Dave Rubin sane people.
How does that make you feel?
- When I write my
next autobiography,
it's gonna be titled, From the
Short Bus to the Shortlist,
The Adam Carolla Story.
Nice to be on the short list.
- Yes, you have
done it, my friend.
All right, first off, I
got to ask you something
because there is a
rumor going around town.
And my guys, my team seemed
to believe this rumor
that you're moving to Texas.
Now, when I talk
about shortlists,
on my shortlist of LA
people, I got Adam Carolla,
I got Dennis Prager,
I got Larry Elder,
Jon Voight, that's it.
Are you leaving us?
Are you going to Houston?
- No, not just yet.
I did a hit on Tucker
Carlson I guess last week
and they brought
the van to my house
and Tucker always does
the, when you leaving LA.
And I think he grew up in,
I think LA and San Diego.
So a lot of the guys
and him and Shapiro
are the two when
you leaving LA guys
because they were
in LA and they left
and I've always been in LA.
So just off the cuff,
because we're in this van,
that was a satellite van,
I just, as an
improvisational comedian,
I just said, oh, Tucker,
as soon as this hits over,
I'm gonna commandeer this van
and I'm driving to Houston.
And for some reason, that
didn't come across a joke
to a lot of people, but
you should have seen
that it was a joke, people,
because if I was
going to Houston,
I would certainly do it
on a Southwest flight.
I don't think I'd commandeer
in $250,000 satellite van.
- You wouldn't take the
satellite van from Fox News
and drive that all
the way to Texas.
You do it first class
on Southwest, I get it.
- I feel like just from
a mileage standpoint,
it would cost much more to
take that satellite van.
- All right, so I'm
glad to hear it.
Sounds like you're
staying for a little bit,
but I did have you over for
dinner a couple of months ago
and you said you were
on a three year plan
and we're watching
Cali just fall apart.
I'm a native New Yorker, but
I've been here seven years.
You're from so Calvert, what
the high hell is going on here?
- Yeah, my kids are just
getting into high school
if you wanna call it
'cause I walked into both
their bedrooms this morning
and they're both laying in bed
with their covers over them.
And I went, hey, I thought
it was school time.
And they were like, hey
we're on the Zoom class,
from underneath the comforter.
What's happened
to LA, it kind of,
I always thought of LA and
even California for sure
as kind of that hot
blonde from high school
that was always the
belle of the ball.
Didn't have to study very hard,
phone rang every Friday
night for a date,
really was able to kind
of get by in her looks
and kind of cruise.
And now that blonde
is 47 years old
and not the belle
of the ball anymore.
And if you listen to
Gavin Newsom, that guy,
I've heard interviews
with him going,
hey man, where are you gonna go?
It's like the 47 year
old blonde saying
to the football star, hey,
don't you want some of this?
And it's like, no, nah,
I can find some of that
in Texas or Arizona or Nevada
or Nashville,
Tennessee or whatever.
But there's a kind of
a thing where it's like
when you're used to being
the belle of the ball,
you don't study that hard.
You don't try that hard.
I mean, California was always
like, we got the beaches,
we got the mountains,
we got Disneyland,
we got all this great stuff.
So it's like, well, what about
how hospitable you
are to business?
Well, don't worry about
that, we got Malibu.
And what they didn't
really factor on,
I mean, there's a few things.
First off, smart people
don't wanna just hang out
and be essentially abused
by their government.
That's number one.
Number two, there's a part
of it that's just practical.
Like I grew up out here,
my parents, my mom
had a VW square back.
She had like a seventies
VW station wagon.
My dad drove a VW bug.
Forget about driving to Arizona,
we couldn't get to Venice
from North Hollywood
without the thing vapor-locking.
And like I talked
to a friend of mine,
Dicky from the Bosstones,
the lead singer
from the band, the Bosstones.
And he was like, yeah,
I moved to Arizona.
I was like, oh,
so you got to go.
He's like, the drive's not bad.
I got a great car.
It's got SiriusXM and
a heater in the seat
and it's like, it's not
that big, like physically,
the transportation,
the 10 flights a day
that are going from Burbank
to Phoenix or JetSuiteX,
like you can get to Salt
Lake city in 55 minutes,
like there's a kind of tangible
mechanical part of this
which is when I was a kid
if you wanted to move,
like buying a ticket on
an airline was a big deal.
Like packing up a rider crock,
again, physically didn't
have cars that could make it.
It's all kind of doable now.
- So what do you think the
future of this town is?
I think you probably have
a couple Hollywood friends
that still talk to you.
I've got one or two
that would not be happy
if I mentioned their name.
But do you think that this town
is just now condemned between
Garcetti at the city level
and Newsom at the state level?
Do you think we are
just truly condemned
and now Gascon, this new DA
who's not gonna arrest
people for prostitution
or resisting arrest or a
series of other things.
Like how much worse can
it get, do you think?
- Well, maybe just a little
bit and then maybe it's time,
like a horrible alcoholic,
maybe this is the,
I've stolen my kids' piggy bank,
I'm gonna break it open
to buy some malt liquor
and I now catch a glance
of myself in the mirror
and I've hit rock bottom.
Like maybe that see you
in the mirror thing,
maybe we're there.
I was thinking about Gascon,
it's like loitering is
not gonna be a problem,
trespassing, not
gonna be problem,
under age drinking, it's
not gonna be a problem,
prostitution, it's not
gonna be a problem.
And I thought, where
the was this guy
when I was in high school?
I could have really used this
DA when I was in high school.
- Not only that, you
can steal up to $900,
that's what they're telling you.
So you could steal a PlayStation
five and like seven games,
but you go into the eight game
range, now you're in trouble.
- Yeah, it all seems like
a very eerie harbinger,
but I hear, you
brought up Hollywood
like our Hollywood friends.
If you think about this,
Los Angeles, Hollywood, LA,
always been the sort of
hub of production, right?
And everything was
filmed, everything,
every TV show anyone
ever saw around the world
was filmed in Burbank
or Culver City
or somewhere in Hollywood.
I mean, I've been on all those,
I've been all the stages,
I've been all the lots,
I used to be at Hollywood Center
Studios doing the Man Show
and we did Crank Yankers
there, I did Loveline there.
And at a certain point,
they started getting greedy.
They started over-regulating.
They started over taxing.
And so what did the most
liberal people on the planet do?
They started drifting
into Atlanta.
They started going to Canada,
started going to Prague.
I mean, they
literally just left.
So it was called
runaway production.
And at some point, some
semi sober person thought,
we can't just have
all of this money
just physically
leaving the state
and they course
corrected a little bit.
They were like, well, why
don't we offer some incentives
for these businesses, Hollywood,
not to leave the state
to do all, as I've probably
told your audience,
I drove from this studio
where I'm sitting right now,
Bryan Cranston came
in and did the show.
Bryan's a good
guy, he's probably
one of the more liberal
guys in Hollywood.
And he said like, I
gotta catch an Uber
to the Burbank Airport.
And I said, I'll drive it
to the Burbank Airport,
it's four miles away.
Then we jumped in my car and
while we were driving there,
he was explaining
that "Breaking Bad"
was supposed to
be filmed out here
but of course, they're
going to New Mexico to film.
And of course they
lost all that money
and all the tourism dollars
and all that kind of stuff.
So at some point, they kind
of wised up and they said,
let's give some incentives
for these guys to stay.
And I got to believe
at some point,
they're gonna try to
do that with business.
- You got to
believe it and yet--
- I got to believe.
- And yet we're in the
lockdown capital of the world.
I mean, you're also
one of the few guys,
I mean, I'm trying to do it too,
but there aren't that
many public people in Cali
that are really publicly
fighting the lockdowns
and trying to get
people back to work.
Your whole sort of
public existence
is sort of based around
the value of work
and your story about work.
And you like people
that work, basically,
you see value in work.
What's your take on
just, nobody's working?
I mean, we got companies with
people working, thankfully,
but a lot of people
aren't working,
- I think the problem,
it's a leftist Democrat
sort of mindset
which is, why do you work?
And the answer is, to
get money, to buy food,
to take care of your
family, to pay rent.
Okay, well, what if
we just paid your rent
and gave you food?
And it's like, well,
that would seem
to handle the problem
mathematically at first glance.
But you're forgetting about a
super important part of work
which is self-worth and
pride and self-esteem
and the depression that
kicks in and all that
once you get on the dull.
So their thing is they
have this bizarre approach
to reverse engineer everything,
like, hey, if a lot
of young black teens
are being suspended
from schools,
then stop suspending
young black teens.
It's like, okay, that's
not gonna fix anything.
If homelessness is illegal
then don't make it
illegal anymore.
And Gascon is that way too.
It's like the prisons are
overcrowded, how do we fix that?
Let everyone out of prison.
Well, that obviously
doesn't fix.
The 75% of the kids can't
do math at grade level.
Well, then lower
the test scores.
It's like, okay, your car's
not going fast enough,
well then, bust the
glass of the speedometer
and take your finger
and turn the needle up
to 80 miles an hour.
You're still going
23 miles an hour.
- Why is it though.
I think I've asked you this
publicly on the show last time
and I know we've talked
about it privately.
Why is it though that so many
people cannot make the jump
from the stupid decisions
to their involvement in
the stupid decisions?
That no matter how many times
they vote in people and policies
that make everything worse.
Like right now, if you and
I walked out of our studios
and we just started talking
to people on the street,
and you said to people,
how's it going in LA?
Everybody would say, man,
it's a freaking mess.
Or if you said how's
Gavin Newsom doing?
They'd all say, horrible.
No, there's nobody defending
these people out there.
There's the rabid
sort of crazies,
but pretty much nobody else.
But why is it and is it
just because of the weather,
it has fried all of
our brains, basically.
It's nice out so
people cannot realize
that the stupid easy answers
aren't the actual answers.
- I've been saying
for a number of years
that all roads
lead to narcissism.
And for the people I
know who vote that way,
they voted that way
and they wanna kind of will
themselves to be correct,
because ostensibly
what you're saying is,
you're a Democrat, yes.
You vote Democrat, yes.
Then you're responsible for
Gavin Newsom and Garcetti, yes.
Well then you're wrong.
The next thing you can
say is you're wrong.
You're wrong, and these are
people that hate being wrong.
They have huge egos and
they never wanna be wrong.
So it's like kind of a
cognitive dissonance.
It's kind of like, yeah,
I voted for that guy
and yeah, he's doing
a horrible job,
but I'm gonna vote
for that party again,
because that way I'll never
have to admit I was wrong,
but you are wrong
because they are running
the state into the ocean.
- The state has no money,
there's homeless
people everywhere,
drug addicts, our
education's horrible.
Do you think maybe we should
try voting for somebody else?
Did you see when, who was it?
Bill Maher had Adam Schiff
on and Maher's complaining.
Maher's going, oh, all of
my friends are leaving LA
because of high taxes
and blah, blah, blah.
And Schiff's like, oh, well,
we're the business
friendly party
and it's meaningless what
he's saying, of course.
But I wanted to kind of smack
Bill Maher through the TV
and be like, what are
you talking about?
You are the one that's
supporting all of these people.
And then all your friends leave
and you wonder why you're alone.
- Well, sometimes they don't
even say, we're the party of,
they just go, well,
people are leaving
because of over-regulation
and high taxes
and a bad business environment.
It's like, yes, they're leaving
because of all the policies
you enacted, those
are your policies.
That's why they're leaving.
- Yeah, they seem to be
unable to make that jump.
Lockdowns, I know
you're not happy.
You're as pissed as I am.
You're you're tweeting
about it all the time.
Do you think there's any,
like on the science level,
do you just think
there's any science
behind any of this
at this point?
I mean, again, right now,
we could both walk out.
We live about 20 minutes
away from each other,
but we can walk
outside of our houses.
It's a beautiful
day as it always is.
We cannot sit outside
and have a coffee
because of lockdowns.
- Yeah, at a place where
you purchase a coffee,
I think we could probably
go up to your roof deck
and enjoy a latte together.
- Yeah, you are always welcome
on my roof deck.
Actually, well, you are
always welcome on my roof deck
but according to Garcetti,
you're not supposed
to be on my roof deck.
- Oh, right, well,
a lot of it is,
most of it is the
crops are dying,
we need a virgin to
throw in the volcano.
And someone goes, how's
that gonna help the crops?
And they go, you shut up,
I got to do something.
The villagers are
upset, they want action.
I mean, whoever the health
minister or czar or whatever
of Los Angeles as
much has admitted it.
It like said outdoor
dining isn't dangerous.
We don't have any data to
support it's dangerous,
but we want people to stay home.
- They literally said that,
you're not making that up.
That is what the guy said, yeah.
- Well, first things first,
do you get to decide who
stays home, that's your job?
Your job is I will decide when
you get to leave your house.
And even if it's for
spurious reasons,
and there is no
direct correlation
between any danger of
spreading the disease
and eating outdoors,
I'm still just gonna
make this random decision
and you shall stay home.
I mean, it's a very, it's
funny, it's a comment
that kind of slid
by a lot of people,
but it's a very scary precedent
when the powers that be
are essentially saying,
you're gonna stay home
because I told you to
stay home and then you go,
give me proof why
I should stay home.
And they go, I don't
have to give you proof.
I told you to stay home.
- But are you shocked how
quickly we all became sheep?
I mean, everybody, everybody.
- Well, what I've
realized, what has happened
is California, especially,
Los Angeles, especially,
it's so over-regulated,
it's so burdensome,
it's so tyrannical and its
leaders are so tyrannical
in terms of its burden that
they put on the taxpayers
that we all got sort of
indoctrinated into this slowly.
Like imagine trying to
pull this off in 1955,
people will obviously be like,
no, I'm not staying home.
And by the way, when I leave
my house, I'm taking my gun
in case one of you assholes
tries to arrest me.
Like that's where
we would be at.
But it was a slow quiet
indoctrination of,
I mean, think about
what you can't do.
Here's what you can't do,
here's what you must do.
Here's all the things.
You can't smoke in a restaurant.
Okay, well, I'll go to
the smoking, no smoking,
okay then I'll go to the
bar, no smoking at the bar.
Well, then I'll go to the
patio, no smoking at the patio.
Like, it's such a crazy
Stockholm syndrome
that everyone lives, everyone
that lives in California
has a kind of a
Stockholm syndrome.
Like I would, I
say all the time,
hey, your business,
your restaurant,
there's no reason why
you need to shut down
your outdoor dining.
You've made a lot
of concessions.
You spent a lot of money.
Just F these guys, stay open.
And it was like, ah, I don't
wanna get into trouble.
Well, that's what the
overregulation has created.
This huge sort of umbrella,
always under the guise of safety
and everyone is just
scared, but slowly scared.
Like, just think
about, you know what?
Think about the beach.
I always talk about the beach,
but think about the beach.
Like imagine telling someone
from the '50s in Malibu,
hey, you can't have that
cigarette on the beach.
What are you doing?
I'm drinking a beer.
You can't drink a
beer on the beach.
I mean, you look at the sign.
I always tell everyone, look
at the sign at the beach.
In the '50s, they
didn't have a sign.
At some point, it
was like, no bonfires
between 3:00 AM and 6:00 AM.
You know what I mean?
Now it's like, no Frisbee,
no dogs, no football,
no cigarettes, no--
- Literally no
humans, no humans.
- Like literally, yeah,
no humans on the beach.
When you think about what,
think about how
they ratchet it up,
think about how the
sign gets longer.
They always add
something to the sign,
they never remove something
from the beach sign.
Every year, there's
two more things
you can't do on the beach.
And when you go physically
look at their signs now,
it is a scroll of things
citizens can't do on our beach.
- So what do you think that is
as a student of the human
mind, as I consider you,
what do you think that thing is?
When you say they meaning they
always make the list longer,
I mean, when you say they, in
essence, you mean us, right?
Like what is wrong with us?
I'm starting to
come around to that.
That there is just something
wrong with the collective us.
That's why I don't
like collectives.
That we are just, gonna not
only do this to ourselves,
but we're gonna pat ourselves
on the back as we do it.
- Well, as our friend,
Dennis Prager always says,
we mistakenly think
people yearn to be free,
but they really yearn
to be taken care of.
They would trade freedom for
security any day of the week.
So if you yearn to
be taken care of,
then you want more
of this government.
And if you yearn to be free,
you want less of
this government.
And the freedom thing, it's
like when we try to liberate
some Middle Eastern nation.
Like, come on, they
want to be free.
No, they don't.
They don't wanna be
free, they wanna be led.
- God, we got freaking
work to do, man.
We've got real work to do. So
what would you do if Carolla,
I've been promoting this
Carolla for governor thing
'cause I jokingly said
it on Fox or on something
and now I was in DC last week
and literally
everybody was asking me
when I'm running for governor,
I'd much rather have
Adam Carolla do it.
But what would you do
if you were governor,
if you were mayor,
like you open us up,
are we open tomorrow?
- I would say, let's follow
the science as they say.
If it seems, first things first,
show me all the countries,
show me all the states,
show me all the cities
that locked down hard
and then I wanna find out what
happened four months later,
like where were they
locked down hard
and now they're
having a huge spike.
What are the difference
between Sweden and Florida
and New York and California.
Like first things first,
I wanna know what
locking down even does.
- It does nothing.
I mean, I think we know
that at this point,
like California,
we live in a state
where we've been in
perpetual lockdown, right?
Some level of serious lockdown.
And you know this,
everywhere you go,
people are wearing masks.
So we've been doing
that since March,
eight, nine months already.
Florida is open.
So shouldn't Florida have
at least doubled the numbers
as us, tripled the numbers,
exponentially higher.
But no, they don't.
So like isn't, I'm
not a scientist.
- And they have the second
most elderly people,
the first in numbers,
but the second percentage
of elderly people as well.
So first things first,
if this isn't doing it,
if locking down isn't doing it,
then we're not gonna lock down.
That's number one.
Number two, as far
as businesses go,
you wanna go to a hair
salon, go to a hair salon.
If you don't feel safe
going to a hair salon,
then don't go to the hair salon.
If you don't feel safe
going inside a restaurant,
then don't go.
We're not making
people go out to dinner
for those who may be compromised
or maybe living with an elderly
person or whatever that is.
I like when this
whole thing started,
it was presumed that everyone
lived with their grandmother.
It's like according to CNN,
87% of Americans lived
with a 90 year old.
Like I would always go,
let my kids just go back
to school and they go,
oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
And I'd go, it doesn't
affect the kids.
They go, oh yeah, but
what about that gaggle
of super old people
that are in your house
that we were unaware
of before the pandemic.
And it's like, I don't know
how many people in California
live with their elderly parents.
And if in fact you are a loser
and you live with
your elderly parents,
then you should make the
decision not to go to the salon.
- But I know you mean
that some good people live
with their elderly parents
because they're
taking care of them.
Now, nobody, it's all to get
the inheritance, basically.
- Yeah.
- All right, let's talk about
the election a little bit.
I'm just giving you
like the whole landscape
of all the craziness
of the world,
the election, where are
you at at this point.
Apparently Joe Biden
is the president elect.
I don't think you
voted for Joe Biden.
Did you officially
announce who you voted for?
I know where you're
at politically,
but did you actually
say it on your show?
- No but I would definitely
vote for Trump over Biden.
The interesting take on it,
which isn't insanely impressive
in terms of the math,
but sort of what Ben Shapiro
is always been talking about
for the last several
weeks which is,
it's not that the election was
rigged per se by the states
or the vote counters
or mail-in ballots.
It's that it was
essentially rigged by CNN,
Los Angeles Times,
New York Times,
most all legacy in mainstream
media and then big tech,
all the Googles and the
Twitter and all that,
it was rigged by
them essentially.
And if you really think about
it, it's not much hyperbole.
I mean, if you think about
just the Hunter Biden's story
as an example.
and you go, okay, and
forget it's Hunter Biden
and forget what the allegations
are and forget anything.
Let's just be generic.
There's a story,
it's a credible story
and it would hurt one candidate.
And I don't know if that means
three points or seven points
or I don't know what it
would translate into,
but it would
definitely be damaging
to one of the candidates.
So in our hypothetical world,
there's A candidate
and B candidate
and B candidate would
definitely be hurt by a story
that comes out several days
before the big election.
And then all the legacy
news organizations
and then Silicon Valley,
they all conspire
to crush a story
and are saying things like
Russian disinformation
or there's no proof whatsoever.
So that story never comes out.
Well, I would argue
that that is tampering
with the election,
it's certainly
affecting the election.
I mean, I guess if you
say what's the definition
of tampering with an election,
I guess the definition would
be affecting the election
one way or the other for this
candidate or that candidate.
So there were all
onboard to do this.
They always do this thing.
It's funny when the smartest
people in the world,
the Silicon Valley guys go,
oh yeah, we didn't know what
was going on with that thing.
We made a mistake.
- We're gonna get
better processes.
We should've looked
at that before.
- Right, you didn't know, huh.
And by the way, pretty simple.
They found the laptop, had a
bunch of information on it.
Might you have some
follow-up questions
or we just announce that's
Russian disinformation.
So you had a whole
group of people.
And when I say a group, I
mean, most 90% of the media,
essentially running interference
for one of the candidates
and all the way through just,
the COVID vaccines
never gonna come out
before the end of
the year, et cetera
and every single story.
Yeah, that's gonna
translate into a few points.
And that is the tampering.
- Do you think there's
anything left at this point
in terms of mainstream media,
like I think if my
one takeaway probably
of the year beyond lockdowns
and the way we give up
freedoms and all that,
but like my one sort
of tangible takeaway
is that there is simply nothing
left in mainstream media.
That doesn't mean
that 100% of reporters
are all bullshit artists,
but I think the way they
treated the Hunter Biden story,
then the way we were
immediately told
not to look at anything
related to election fraud
and if we did, we're
basically Alex Jones
and everything else, like
to me, there's nothing left.
Washington Post, New York
Times, CNN, like it's just done.
Am I over the top?
- Well, there's something left,
but the question is, what
did they do to their brand?
So if you think about what
the Oscars means in 2021
versus the Oscars
from our childhood.
First off, it was appointment
viewing, get the whole family,
see who the best picture
of the year, who got the,
and the best picture
of the year got,
that was the best
picture of the year.
I mean, we didn't argue about it
and we didn't think there
was any politics involved
and it just was.
And by the way, when you look
at the ratings for these shows,
you realize it ain't what it
used to be by a long shot.
And I'll give you
a couple examples.
So think about the Oscars,
think about the Emmys.
Think about how, I did a
little experiment around here,
I have young people work for me.
I said if you heard a story
out of CNN five years ago,
what would you have thought?
And they went, I would
have believed it.
And I'd say, what
do you think now?
And they go, eh, I'd
have to go look into it.
So CNN, New York Times, all
the entities you mentioned,
but also Oscars, Emmys, maybe
the NBA, Rotten Tomatoes,
you see, "Hillbilly Elegy",
oh, it's 24% with the critics
but 88 with the people.
Oh, what a shocker.
"No Safe Spaces"
is, I don't know,
44% with the critics
and 90% with the people.
So now we no longer
have to go to,
we don't have to find out
what the critics have to say
on Rotten Tomatoes
because it's skewed.
Everything is skewed.
And whoever wins the
Oscar is gonna be,
oh, he's the black gay teen
who is struggling
with his sexuality.
It's like, okay, I get it.
And by the way,
when you do that,
you are shaking
hands with the devil.
You really are in
terms of your brand,
the Oscars should have never let
all this super woke shit in.
Because once you announce,
we now need 50% people
of color nominated
for the best actor, it's over.
We stop, we go, were
are they the best actors
or is they just meeting a quota?
So they're shooting
themselves in the foot.
- But the best part
of it is they decided
to put all these quotas in about
skin, color, and sexuality.
And if you're a midget or you
have a lazy eye or whatever,
except they said, we're not
gonna do it for three years.
It's so important to
solve racism and sexism,
but we still have
some stuff in the can.
So we got to get that
racist crap out of the way
and we'll do it in three years.
You mentioned "No Safe Spaces"
so I'm sure most of my
audience has seen it already
but when you think
back to the project,
'cause you guys probably
you and Dennis and the team
probably started
working on this thing,
what like four years ago
maybe, something like that?
When you think back
to the project,
I mean it basically everything,
and I'm not just saying it
'cause we both
happened to be in it.
But everything that "No
Safe Spaces" is about,
which in essence is that
all of this woke craziness
from the college campus is
gonna leak into real society.
It's what everyone sees now.
And we were all told we were
racists and bigots and the rest
for talking about it.
Are you kind of,
are you like impressed
that we kind of called it
or are you depressed
or just, this is what it is?
'Cause we called it,
we all called it.
Now everyone knows
that that is the stuff
that is happening
everywhere right now.
- Well, first off,
how could it not?
Like, what if your
kid leaves for college
and then every one of
their professors is a vegan
and then they're teaching
classes on meat is murder,
don't tell your chef husband
'cause he makes a
delectable Wagyu, I think.
- By the way, did I hear
correctly on your podcast,
I think the day or two after
you came over here for dinner,
I think you said it was the
best steak you've ever had.
- It was man.
So kudos to you for a
living with that kid.
- Hey I handled the stake,
I was doing the stake.
- Oh damn, you're right.
- I did the stake.
You were there when I
was flipping it, man.
He did the sides.
- Yeah I know.
I had a couple of
scotches at that point.
Sorry, Dave, you get,
all credit to Dave Rubin
for doing doing the steak,
but the hell we're talking
about, and I forgot about it.
- That if you send your
kids to these schools
and they're being
taught by vegans.
- Oh yeah, okay, so everyone's
a vegan and meat is murder.
How long before your
kids starts coming home
for Thanksgiving and saying,
no, thanks to the turkey
because meat is murder.
And then when those kids
in their vegan environment get
pushed out into Main Street
and Madison Avenue and start
showing up at corporations,
how long before they
start judging people
for eating a ham sandwich and
how could it go any other way?
Of course, it's
gonna go that way.
I mean, you go to this place
where a bunch of
ideology is taught to you
and then the
construct or at least,
college is basically there to,
I mean, if you think about,
what is the mission
statement for a college?
Well, you go to this
place for four years,
we teach you a bunch of stuff
and then you take that with
you into society, right?
Well, we just thought it was
gonna be a bunch of engineering
and calculus and art, history,
we didn't know it was
gonna be an indoctrination
to a bunch of ideas, but it is.
And I would argue those
ideas are more powerful
than engineering are
because you can't just walk
into your new job at Kinko's
and start talking to everyone
about structural
engineering or shear loads
or tension anchors or something,
it's not going to take,
but if you start talking to
everyone about your ideology,
then it's gonna spread
and that's exactly
where we're living.
- So how do you
make sure your kids,
they're not college age yet.
But how do you make sure that
they're not getting infected
with this stuff?
Because from everyone that
I know that's a parent
in this town, even
if they're going
to the most elite
private school,
people that are even in
religious private schools,
I'm talking Catholic schools,
Orthodox, Jewish schools,
like the woke-ism has now
infected virtually everything.
How do you make sure that stuff
doesn't get through
to your kids?
- Well, I don't give a shit.
I'll be in Houston by the
time they get to college,
remember the plan?
I don't think, you see, I
don't think you should wrestle
with them over ideas.
It's going to have an effect.
My son is very conservative.
He's a Dave Rubin fan.
He's a Dennis Prager fan.
He's a Ben Shapiro fan.
He loves all that stuff.
I didn't have to wrestle
with him over ideas.
My daughter's very progressive.
The reason my daughter's
very progressive
is because she
wants to be liked.
And my son doesn't really care.
He's just a doofus dude,
but my daughter
wants to be popular.
And if you wanna be popular,
you better be down with
Black Lives Matter.
My feeling with kids is,
you shouldn't really
get preachy with them,
but you definitely need
to lead by example.
Like you just go,
here's what I do.
Like almost every
time I go to work,
I just go, I'm going to work
today because that's what I do.
And I would do things like
when I would go out on a Friday
night to the comedy store
and do a set, I
would go to my son,
I'm gonna go to my
daughter and I'd go,
okay, it's eight o'clock
and I'm going from La Canada
to Hollywood, to Sunset Strip,
and I'm gonna go there
and I'll be back at 11
and I'm not getting paid.
I'm doing this for free.
I'm doing this to get
better at what I do.
That's what I'm doing,
and I would leave.
And I just would imprint in
them that there's no shortcuts.
It's hard work, lead by example.
And I don't know that you're
gonna be able to talk them,
I don't think you can
talk them out of anything.
You can show them who
you are and how you live.
- Is that tough
for your daughter?
Because you are you,
like your daughter's friends
must know who you are.
You talk about this stuff.
Has that been an issue?
- No, my daughter,
I was just out,
took her and her friends
out driving the other night.
They understand who I am
on a sort of human level.
They understand I'm a good guy.
They understand
I'm like a fun dad
and I provide a lot of stuff
and we get to do lots of
fun stuff because of me.
And I'm sure if we ever sat down
and really got into a
political conversation,
we'd end in a huge argument
as my son and my
daughter frequently do.
But no, I think it's
important and I feel this way
about relationships that
I've had in Hollywood.
They need to know who you are.
They need to know that
you're a good person,
that you're family oriented,
that you pay your taxes.
Like they need to understand
because we all know it's just
a big smear campaign, right?
Racist, sexist, where
you disagree with
someone on the left
and it's 'cause you're
homophobic or xenophobic
or whatever, misogynistic.
It's really harder
when they have to argue
with a human being.
When the conceit is,
that's a good person,
he loves his family and
he's a good citizen.
And now we're just left with
what we agree and disagree on.
So I think you can sort of
have that with your kids.
Like, I really feel
like they need to,
you can't tell them don't
smoke while you're smoking.
You know what I mean, you have
to kind of lead by example,
and that's kind of my approach.
- So kind of tying that to
the political part of it.
I mean, we don't
have much of that.
We're being told right now,
if you listen to the media
and the Biden thing,
like now's the time
for us to come together.
No more of the meanness.
I'm a president for
everybody, all that stuff.
It strikes me as very fake
because all of these people,
the media, all the Democrats,
basically, the establishment,
if Trump had won,
and by the way,
I'm still not convinced
this thing is over
which I'd love to hear
your thoughts on as well,
but if it was reversed,
if Trump had just
won on November 3rd,
they'd all be screaming,
burn it all down.
But now there's
sort of this fake,
like, oh, let's kind
of be friends thing.
Do you think there's
any authenticity there?
Or even any value to it?
It doesn't seem valuable to me.
Like, oh, you got what you want.
You're the child
who got the cookie.
So now we can be friends again.
But if it had gone the other
way, no, no, no, no, no.
- I do think there's
way too much,
and a lot of it was just
a way to attack Trump.
It's like, he sets the
tempo for the country.
Like people were like,
it's like, he told
everyone to inject bleach
into their veins.
People listened to him,
like who injected bleach,
who drank bleach.
- I know a couple of people
I wish had drank bleach,
but nobody actually did it.
- Who did all these things?
Like, well, when he says
things, you have to understand
that so many people it's
like, eh, I don't know.
Do we really take
our sort of cues
from a etiquette standpoint
from the president?
I think the conceit,
so what's going on now
is they created,
the left created
so much chaos around Trump.
And so now their thing was like,
don't you just want it to end,
don't you just want
the curse to end.
So it's almost like somebody
broke in your house,
let five macaw parrots go inside
and then was yelling at you,
don't you want this to end?
And you're like, I do, but why
did you break into my house
and let five macaw parrots loose
and they go, you want
it to end, right?
I want it to end.
It's like, okay, but you're the
one who let the parrots out.
And then at some point,
the second part of the
narrative has to be,
well now, that that's
over, let's preach unity,
but it's never gonna manifest
itself in any real way.
And it already hasn't.
And I think it's
all lip service.
- So do you think we're
irreparably broken right now.
Like, I don't know anyone truly,
I don't think I know
anyone that supported Trump
that fully thinks that
this thing was legit.
And if that's the case,
regardless of who's sworn in
on the 20th, I
mean, we've got like
a seriously broken system.
Even me, like my
faith in the system
is seriously broken right now,
which makes it hard
in a way to be someone
that communicates ideas
the way that we do,
because I'm trying to be
honest with my audience
and my faith in the things
that we talk about is shaken.
- Well, I think in terms
of how it manifests itself,
and maybe this just
sounds self-congratulatory
or something,
but if you take a look at
the physical manifestation
of unrest and you take
a look at NT fund,
Black Lives Matters and
all that kind of stuff,
they're out in the street,
they're lighting stuff on fire.
They're looting, they're
costing elderly couples
that are eating outside
and drinking their wine
and dumping it on their
head and everything.
That's basically how they act
when they don't get their way.
The right and the conservatives
don't act that way
when they don't get their way,
they're probably equally
as unhappy about it,
but it doesn't really manifest.
And all the assholes are like,
well, what about the Klan?
Or what about the proud West?
Okay, there's 10 of them.
Like when's the last time you
saw the Klan take over a city
and have the cops stand down
and burn everything down
and loot everything?
- I think I watched
"Time to Kill,"
I think that was when
it was, I think in 1993.
And it was a movie about
40 years before that, yeah.
- Right, okay.
So I think that the
conservatives who by nature
are just more, they're
more conservative,
they're not as impulsive.
They're not gonna go out
and start burning things.
I think they're
gonna be unhappy.
They're gonna feel
like they got jabbed
in this last election.
They're probably gonna sit
back and laugh a little
as the Democrats start
with the infighting
and the AOC side of it
starts getting into it
with the Biden side of it.
And they're gonna watch
him kind of crash and burn.
And then it's gonna
be really easy
to get a Dan Crenshaw
type in Trump again.
Or if there's a host of strong
candidates on the right,
and it'll just set the table
to repeat what just
happened four years ago.
- Do you think it's kind of
funny that maybe 15 years ago
when you were doing Loveline
and doing The Man Show
and everything else,
that you would end up
talking about politics
as much as you do?
I know you talk
about everything,
but like everything is now
politics in a weird way.
Do you think it's kind of odd?
- I never really think about it.
I always wanted to kind of do
something a little different
than I did the year before and
kind of evolve a little bit.
Also there's an
interesting phenomenon
which is when people say,
you've changed, to me,
I say to them, name me one thing
that I've changed my mind on
since I was on Loveline 25 years
ago, you name me one thing.
If you'd asked me
about border security,
I would have been for it.
If you'd asked me
about gay marriage,
I would have been for it.
If you would have asked me
about decriminalizing pot,
I would have been for it.
If you would ask
me about voter ID,
I would have been for it.
I wouldn't, if you'd ask
me about lowering taxes,
I would have been for it.
- That's the worst episode
of Lovelines I ever heard.
- It's super boring
for the 14 year olds,
but I have not changed
my opinion on anything.
That's the way, but it wasn't
considered political then,
you weren't
considered political.
Now, everything gets pushed
through this sort of prism
of politics.
I still don't look at
myself as a political,
I look at myself as
giving my opinions.
Like when you go, should you
present an ID when you vote?
I go, well, do you need an ID
to buy a pack of cigarettes
or to get on an airplane, yes.
Okay, then you
need an ID to vote.
Okay, so you're this
political person, right?
And it's like, no, that's
just my opinion on that.
But on the other
side of the aisle,
I'm all for gay marriage.
And I don't feel that's
political either.
I didn't feel like it's,
I know it gets seen
through the prism
of something political.
I don't feel it's political.
I feel like you're asking me,
should we have a strong border?
And I go, yes.
And that's where I'm at.
That's where I'm
at with everything.
- That just means you're
racist, not political.
- Right, that's right.
- All right, let's
talk about something
really political then,
because how many books
have you written?
Is it four?
- Five.
- I feel like it's five,
you've written five books.
And as far as I know,
according to my research here,
three of your books have made
the New York Times
bestseller list.
But your last book, Adam
Carolla, did not make it,
but we know that the New
York Times bestseller list
is a crock of shit.
How does it make you feel to
not make a list that we know,
I mean, I know you know
the internal numbers.
You obviously probably
should have been
number two or something
the week that you came out,
does that stuff
bother you anymore?
Or do you just like,
it is what it is?
- Yeah, I'm kind of,
it is what it is.
It's kind of weird when
you see that you outsold
a bunch of books
that are on the list.
And when you look at
the title of the book,
all something to do with race,
all something to do with gender,
all something that whatever,
then you understand,
and it's a little
frustrating momentarily
because you go, oh, we should be
on the New York Times
bestseller list.
But you also, and a
good example of somebody
who's diluted their brand,
they've compromised their brand.
New York Times bestseller
list, Oscars, Rotten Tomatoes,
they've diluted it, they're
hurting their brand.
It doesn't, if I now hear a book
is on the New York
Times bestseller list,
or more importantly,
didn't make it
on the New York Times bestseller
list, I got questions.
I never would have had
questions 15 years ago,
which has been well,
they had one book,
sold more than the other book
that would have been
it, zero questions.
Now I have questions and
that's what they've done.
And I don't think they know
the kind of long-term damage
that they're doing
to their brand.
Again, New York Times bestseller
list, that's a huge brand,
Oscars, huge brand,
but if it was a stock,
you would see the arrow heading
down over the last 10 years.
- It's funny when my book
was coming out in April
and everybody kept, all
the publishers, agents,
we wanna get you on the New
York Times best seller list,
we want you on the New
York Times bestseller list.
And I kept saying everybody,
but you're all
telling me it's fixed,
that the whole thing's fixed,
but you wanna get on it.
You wanna get on the fixed list.
And it's like, we're all
running for something
that kind of doesn't
exist in a weird way.
And I thought, well, if
they mess with their lists
that should be about
just sales, right?
The top list, it's like,
well, it kind of tells you
what they're doing on the
editorial pages as well,
or on the news pages as well.
- Oh, for sure.
And again, the only
part that frustrates me
and you're talking to a guy
who's made a bunch of movies
that were very well received
and none of them have gotten
into Sundance, none of them.
And, again, if you look at
the people on Rotten Tomatoes,
you'll see 100%,
95%, very good docs.
I mean, I have three of these
docs on Netflix right now.
Netflix bought all three
of these documentaries.
Certainly good enough to
make the cut at Sundance.
None of them have
gotten into Sundance
and nor shall any doc I
ever make get into Sundance.
And the part that frustrates me,
whether it be
getting into Sundance
or the New York Times
bestseller list,
is that people don't
know what's going on.
The people, general
society's like,
well, if you didn't
get into Sundown,
make a better film next time.
You don't get it.
There is no Sundance for me.
There is no New York Times
bestseller list for me.
There is none of that for me.
That it's never going to happen.
And you guys think it's about
the quality of the product.
- I can hear my
audience screaming.
So Carolla, why don't
you conservatives
build different institutions?
Why isn't there the
Carolla Film Festival?
Why isn't there the La
Canada Film Festival?
- Well, there's gonna be,
and parlor and places like that.
I mean, it's going to happen.
I mean, if you take a look,
it is funny, about
two years ago,
if you looked at the iTunes
charts, one through 50,
there was no conservative
shows podcasts on there,
maybe Shapiro, but I
mean, really nothing else.
You go look now there's 10.
They created that.
They actually, the
mainstream media
and all these places where,
they're the best thing
that ever happened
to Dan Bongino, right, or
Charlie Kirk or whomever, right?
They raided their business
through trying to
suppress all these ideas.
And so there will be a new
New York Times bestseller list
or a new Sundance or whatever,
or the whole thing
will just be antiquated
and no one will care anymore.
Like who cares if you got into
this film festival or not?
Is the film good or not?
Where can I find it?
- Right, it'll probably
be, can you, Adam Carolla,
get to your audience somehow.
And if you get your stuff
to enough of your audience,
then that's probably
good enough.
That's probably it.
So as we enter the final stages,
the final last few
days of this 2020,
and we roll into Christmas,
what else is on your
mind at the moment?
Like what else are you
thinking about that,
not this sort of day to day
stuff that we're talking about
and the political,
and it's like,
what else has just been sort
of interesting to you lately?
- I've been really
kind of drilling down
and speaking to Dr.
Drew quite frequently
about people's reaction
to this pandemic
and what colossal cowards so
many people have turned into
and why so fertile,
why is this soil so
fertile for these cowards
and what's really going on.
And something I really
been thinking about is risk
and then risk assessment.
And I started to think about
all the guys I work with.
And I work with a lot
of guys restoring cars
and building houses, doing so,
half my life is creative
and the other half is
kind of blue collar.
And I noticed that
the blue collar guys
were always very even,
they're not worried about it.
As a matter of fact, I don't
think I've ever discussed COVID
with any of the guys in my shop.
They're literally
not interested.
They just get up and go to work.
And then I started
thinking about
their relationship with
risk is very finely tuned.
Because if you're
to fire up a lave
and put a ingot
of aluminum on it,
you got to start taking
a sharp knife to it,
a chisel to it or something,
you better have your
relationship figured
out with danger.
And also what things,
so when you work construction
and you work carpentry,
you have to pick up a tool and
the tool's got a blade on it,
and you got to use it,
but you have to use it in
such a way where you're safe,
but you still have
to get the job done.
And so there's a constant
calibration going on,
like because you're
gonna lose a finger
or you're gonna lose an arm
or you're gonna lose your life
if you don't really
get this relationship
worked out with danger.
So I don't think loggers are
nearly as scared of COVID
as guys who do data entry.
Because when you then get into
this air condition cubicle,
you no longer have
to assess risk.
You don't have, if you're
a window washer or a roofer
or whatever, like if you
do what we used to do
when a huge percentage of
society would go to a factory
or go to the sawmill
or go to the lumberyard
or do whatever it is,
this sort of blue collar
tangible hands-on jobs,
it's constant risk assessment.
It's just, can this
scaffolding hold me?
'Cause I'm going up
to the third floor.
It's just, it's a constant,
and you're not aware of it,
it's just your brain
is constantly worrying.
So when you see COVID, those
guys have assessed the risk
and it's minimal.
All the people that are sitting
around watching CNN all day
on a Zoom call are
not calibrated.
So they're all inflated.
And the more of our society
that kind of gets off
the construction site
and gets off, think about
when you work on a farm.
Every second is some sort
of risk assessment, right?
All the equipment you're
dealing with and whatnot.
The more of our society that
moves into the digital world,
the more difficulty we're
gonna have assessing risk
and that's what we're
living right now.
- Then on that
note, bring us home
with some hopeful stuff for
21, for 2121, I was gonna say,
give me something for
2121, do we still exist?
Or give me something for 2021.
- Anyone listening,
you cannot just reside
in the digital world.
You will go insane.
You will lose your bearings.
You must get something
tangible in your life.
I don't care if it's gardening.
I don't care if it's crocheting,
get down to the garage
and start a project.
Put a patio, put a
pergola on your home.
You have a beautiful pergola
in the back of your home deck.
Go out there, physically
get your hands dirty.
If you're just
gonna go down the,
I'm gonna watch CNN and
order Grubhub all day,
you will go insane
and you see it all
over the place.
You see these middle-aged
people like spazzing out
on other people who
aren't wearing a mask
walking alone on a horse trail.
They can't assess risk.
It's the death of math.
You need to put yourself in
some vulnerable positions.
If something scares you a
little bit, you got to go do it.
Go out whitewater
rafting or something.
You have to get outside.
You have to get in
a tangible world
and you have to have projects.
And by the way, once
you have a project
like a tangible project,
then you're in
problem solving mode.
Your brain is occupied.
You're not thinking
about global warming.
You're not thinking, you're
trying to solve problems
on a micro level
not a macro level,
trying to solve world
hunger or systemic racism
or global warming, you
will slowly go insane
because there's no finish
line, you'll never solve it.
You'll just be
preoccupied with it.
- Carolla, all I had
to do was loft it up,
you took care of the rest.
Merry Christmas, my friend.
I'm glad you're at least
temporarily staying in LA.
And 'cause then I
thought, Oh God,
am I gonna have to move to
Houston and it's so humid
and the hair would
be so flat there.
You've got that nice curly
hair, it doesn't really matter.
But for me it would just...
- Yeah, but--
- But I guess for
you, it would do this.
- Yeah, it'll go out
like the hair bear bunch.
If you're planning on
broiling some more meat,
definitely shoot me a text
man because I will be there.
- There will be meat.
And by the way you
mentioned my rooftop before,
we just put up four three
foot by four foot planters.
So we're doing a
little gardening.
So I'm living the Carolla
lifestyle up over here.
And actually I do have a
couple of stucco things
I need you to fix.
So I'll text after this.
- I'll bring my sponge tray.
- All right, see you, Adam.
- Thanks Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about comedy
instead of the nonstop yelling
you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.